[MUSIC PLAYING]
WESLEY CHUN: Hi, developers.
Welcome to "Serverless
Migration Station,"
where we show you
one way you can
modernize your code on one
of our serverless compute
platforms.
I'm Wesley Chun, joined
by my friend, Martin,
and our little friend,
Porter, to take you
on an alternate journey from
App Engine into Cloud Run.
MARTIN OMANDER: Good
to be here again, Wes.
You showed us how to
containerize our app
for Cloud Run last time.
Why are we doing it again today?
WESLEY CHUN: Well, I'm
glad you asked, Martin.
In the module 4 video,
we did show developers
how to use Docker to
containerize our App Engine
apps for Cloud Run.
Check it out if you missed it.
Containerizing your App
Engine app for Cloud Run
is still on to do list
today, but this time, we'll
do it without needing to know
about Docker, or Docker files,
or how containers
are put together.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK,
that sounds great.
But how are we going
to containerize
an app without Docker?
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah.
Well, we're going to use Google
Cloud Buildpacks to do the job.
Instead of having to describe
all the steps for building
the container, Buildpacks
lets you off the hook
because it does
the heavy lifting.
It looks at your code,
what language it's in,
its third-party
dependencies, and so on,
then builds the most efficient
container image it can.
Check out these links
and this video from one
of our colleagues to learn
more about Cloud Buildpacks.
MARTIN OMANDER:
That's good info.
But I'm curious, where did
these Buildpacks come from?
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah, well,
they originated from Heroku
back in 2011.
And since then,
Buildpacks took off
for different languages,
different cloud vendors.
But in 2018, the Cloud Native
Computing Foundation unified
Buildpacks under
a common standard.
Google Cloud Buildpacks
are 100% compatible
with the Cloud Native Buildpacks
and adheres to its open spec.
Check out the links to the Cloud
Native Buildpacks and its spec.
Cloud Buildpacks
containerizes apps
to be deployed on Google
Cloud, whether Cloud Run,
GKE, which is our managed
Kubernetes service,
or Compute Engine VMs.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, sounds good.
I can't wait to try it.
So I did look ahead
and I found out
there's one module 5 finish
folder, which is Python 3.
What happened to Python 2, Wes?
WESLEY CHUN: Well,
unfortunately, Buildpacks
don't support Python 2.
So if you do have a Python 2
app, you got to use Docker.
But so our starting point
will be the Python 3 version
of the Maldo 2 Cloud NDB app.
We didn't containerize that
one with Docker last time,
so let's pause right
now so all of you
can go grab the code from
the module 2b folder,
or use your own from
the module 2 migration.
Got it?
You can also follow
along in the codelab
and get hands-on experience
containerizing it
with Cloud Buildpacks.
Let's start by confirming
the module 2 code works.
Whether using your app or ours,
redeploy with gcloud app deploy
and verify you get
the same output
as from previous modules.
If you've done any of
these migration modules,
you know that this app
typically doesn't change at all.
That's the purpose, right?
Migrating without
breaking anything?
Just like in module 4,
we're switching products
from App Engine to
Cloud Run, so make
a full copy of your
module2 app folder,
because like with Docker,
you're going to delete app.yaml,
as it's not used in Cloud Run.
Next, let's tackle
requirements.txt.
Quick review.
App Engine and Cloud
Functions are source-based
and start your app with a
production-ready server.
Since Cloud Run is a
little bit more DIY,
you have to roll your own.
Python App Engine uses gunicorn
if you don't specify your own,
so we're going to use
that with Cloud Run
by adding it to
requirements.txt,
so it's identical to the
one in module2b folder
except with gunicorn
at the top, since I
like to put mine in lowest
to highest level order.
Yes, version numbers
are a good practice.
I left them out here because
they change all the time.
However, they will be
updated in the repo.
Like with Docker, the app
itself doesn't change.
We're just
containerizing it, right?
The last thing needed
is to launch gunicorn
to start our app.
With Docker, there's either
a command or entry point
directive at the end
of the Docker file
to kick off gunicorn.
With Cloud Buildpacks, there
is no app.yaml nor Dockerfile.
Instead, we use a
Heroku-style Procfile.
It's basically a config file
describing your app's processes
and how to start them.
For our app, there's only
one process, the web server.
It's basically the entry
point directive from app.yaml
or the Dockerfile.
So create yours with this
one line specifying gunicorn
as our web process.
And boom, that is it.
We're also going to drop
some links down below so you
can learn more about Procfiles.
And that, we say, is a wrap.
Run the same gcloud
run deploy SVC_NAME --
.
Command as you did with
Docker, or the longer version,
with the platform type,
region, and so on,
if you're lazy like me.
And in about a minute
or less, your app
will be available
globally on Cloud Run.
It should work the same as
before, whether on App Engine
or Cloud Run with Docker.
Now you've containerized
your App Engine app again,
but this time,
without a Dockerfile.
Congratulations.
MARTIN OMANDER: Wow.
I didn't know
creating and deploying
a container would be that easy.
Buildpacks are amazing.
Since I don't have to worry
about Dockerfiles anymore,
I'm thinking about how to
increase my app's presence.
While my users here in the
US don't have any issues,
my friends in Sweden are
saying it's sometimes laggy.
Can I deploy my container
to other regions?
WESLEY CHUN: Oh,
for sure, Martin.
In these past few videos,
we used the magic one-line
build and deploy command to
get you started with the least
friction.
That's gcloud run
deploy with --source
to specify the code to deploy.
For more sophisticated usage,
let's talk about breaking it up
into two separate
commands that'll
make it more flexible
to do the other things,
like what you asked.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Sounds good, Wes.
I'm willing to give up some
convenience so I can more
easily deploy my app elsewhere.
But you said that one-line
command builds and deploys
my container.
Can I guess that the
two separate commands
are one for the build and
the other for the deploy?
WESLEY CHUN: Precisely.
With the one-line
command, we got your app
from code all the
way to Cloud Run
without discussing container
images or other resources,
like Cloud Build, Container
Registry, or its successor,
Artifact Registry.
But since the cat's
out of the bag,
here's the gcloud build
submit --tag command.
You provide the full
image path, which
is made up of the
registry namespace,
like gcr.io or package.dev,
respectively, your project
ID, image name, and
possibly the region.
When you build
your image, it has
to be registered before you
can deploy to Cloud Run.
Registries help manage images,
provide access control,
lets you check for
vulnerabilities,
and is where you plug
into CI/CD integrations.
Check out the
links to the gcloud
build submit command, as well as
both registries, to learn more.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, so that's
the build and register step.
Now how do I deploy the
same container image
to multiple regions?
WESLEY CHUN: Hold on.
We're getting there, Martin.
Now that the image
is in the registry,
it's straightforward to deploy.
But instead of gcloud
run deploy --source,
it's gcloud run
deploy --image, where
you provide the image pathname.
Using this command, you
can deploy the same image
to other regions without having
to build identical containers.
Another benefit to having
your image in the registry
is that you can launch
services directly
from the Cloud Console whenever
you want from wherever you are.
In other words, you don't
have to be on a command line
at your terminal.
You can be in Sweden to
launch that service there.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, I feel good
about containerizing my App
Engine app for Cloud Run.
What are some other App
Engine migrations to consider?
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah, well,
where you usually go usually
depends on the
services you're using.
Apps using Cloud
NDB may consider
migrating to Cloud
Datastore if you have
other code using that library.
If so, take a look at module 3.
But if all you have are
apps using Cloud NDB,
just stay where you are.
If you're excited about the
Firebase features in Cloud
Firestore, you can consider that
migration in modules 6 and 10.
If your app uses App
Engine task queues,
consider migrating
to Cloud Tasks.
You can learn more about
those in modules 7, 8, and 9.
Finally, if your app only
has one basic function
or if you're interested in
breaking up a larger App Engine
app into a set of microservices,
check out module 11
to learn about migrating
to Cloud Functions.
MARTIN OMANDER: Whoa.
That's a lot of options.
Thanks for pointing us to
possible next stops, as well as
these last two
videos showing users
how to containerize their App
Engine apps for Cloud Run.
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah,
and thank all of you
for staying with us on
these short journeys
in modernizing your
serverless apps.
This is Wesley Chun from
Google Cloud on behalf
of Martin and Porter,
and we look forward
to seeing you at the
next "Migration Station"
or on another "Serverless
Expedition" soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]